that's actually one that I was working
on before the Noah book before these
other books that got published I was
sort of halfway through that I love pop
culture I love monster movies I grow up
on him I still watch him the cheesier
the better that 1950s black and white
with a really bad acting I love all that
stuff and my original impulse was to to
take this incredibly humble material
this really yeah it's bad stuff and to
try to elevate it to try to present it
like as Shakespeare like it's Greek
tragedy like it's some cut you know what
the monster that gets you know blown off
the Empire State Building or wherever is
this huge tragic figure like King Lear
or somebody or you know Oedipus who just
has some flaw that that brings about his
downfall um I had no particular notion
of where that would go but i just wanted
to explore the tension between um yet
really low grade material with really
high class um treatment i just thought
it would be kind of funny and and maybe
interesting and maybe it would reveal
something and as i worked on it i kept
sort of taking detours and the the ideas
just sort of kept spreading and suddenly
stuff from the 50s kept creeping into
the book and i realized that it was not
only was it a monster movie that it was
sort of grounded in the events of its
time which are always completely absent
from these movies you watch them all
these movies from the 50s and there's
never any mention of the world at you
political situation or what was
happening in the US or anywhere else at
the time
there's maybe some nuclear testing right
which makes the giant spider but that's
as much as you ever get and so I found
that all that kind of stuff kept
creeping into the to the mix and in that
seem interesting and it seemed like
maybe that was actually what the story
was about to some degree and I just kind
of ran with it it was fun but it's
interesting because originally i was
actually going to make it explicitly a
king kong retake and then I began to
wonder number one if that was the most
interesting thing and number two if you
know I'd legally be able to do it so
that was my first impulse in naming him
k instead of Kong it also echoes Kafka
which I like because all his characters
I think our K or Joseph K or somebody in
in the you know the penal colony or
whatever i'm not sure but then I realize
now don't don't make it a giant gorilla
that's stupid but then I I I wanted a
monster but I didn't know what kind of
monster and then I realized rather than
picking one specific kind of thing just
to throw them all together so you have
you know insect elements and you have
lizard reptile elements and you have fur
and you have feathers and you have teeth
and you have everything um rather than
you know a giant bird or a giant praying
mantis or a giant whatever just throw
them all together and make them just the
uber monster you know I'll just the
ultimate the ultimate killing machine is
because when I was striving for of
course he's a vegetarian
well if you watch enough of these movies
that I have you you begin to see
repeating types I mean that's another
thing about these movies the
characterization is non-existent um
they're they're not meant to be
individuals and I mean this hasn't
changed i want to see Cloverfield last
week you know great movie by the way and
again I mean it was there were the same
you know types were there but you have
you know you have the leading man the
handsome leading man who's in charge of
the of the expedition and then you have
his usually his wife or his fiancee or
something who's involved and you have
the kind of wisecracking sidekick and
you also often have a scientist who
actually I I left out of this and you
have the chief of police and you know
the military man who's steadfast and you
know who knows a little more than you
think and I wanted to play with all
these people I wanted to both have them
fit within the recognized of typecasting
and yet also maybe have have a hints of
things that go outside of what you would
have seen if you'd actually gone to
these movies that you know some things
happen in these movies that I mean in
this book that you never saw in any of
those movies and I wanted to sort of
begin with a base of their stereotyped
character but but then kind of twist it
or distort it or or shift it to one side
and and make it creepy
well originally the impulse was yet to
line it up with the movie um because I
mean the 50s with the Golden Age but you
know if what I found and this is one
reason why sort of external world events
started creeping in if you look at what
was happening in the 50s and you look at
some of what's some of the things that
are on people's minds today there are
very strong connections okay you could
probably say that about any ten year
period like since you know Jonah or
whatever but it is true that you know
for example in the 50s Iran had a
democratically elected prime minister
you know that the United States and the
UK got rid of and threw in jail and we
put in the Shah who was a king because
he was more receptive to the oil
industry's needs in the West 25 years
later the Iranians throw them out and
now all were worried that they're
building H bombs and stuff I didn't have
that in mind when I began reading the
story writing the story but everybody is
all concerned about Iran right now and
they hate freedom won't hold up a minute
they they fought for freedom 50 years
ago we got rid of it and I just think
those those connections need to be
remembered and need to be acknowledged I
mean I you know I think the States needs
to issue an apology for that never will
see in some ways I think that it might
have really helped I've said this to
that living overseas I think and maybe
specifically living in Pakistan has is
one reason I'm a writer it's one reason
I'm published I am NOT saying that you
have to do that I'm just saying that
maybe I think I had to do that because
when I was in the States you know I just
kind of lived an ordinary white guy
little class of life and you know
everybody I knew went to the store and
had thanksgiving and watched football
games and whatever i'm interested the
set of the basic understanding of the
order of the world was shared by
everybody around me there's nothing
wrong with that but when i left that and
i started living in places where that
worldview or that understanding of
things just wasn't a given i first of
all found myself looking at my own you
know basic premises and also i began
being able to see the world through
different eyes which is the job
description of a writer is to look at
the world through different eyes and
needing to understand let's say
somebody's point of view when they were
asking me about a policy of the US or
something enabled me to practice just to
get to know other people worldviews
better I sit down to write not this book
but say the NOAA book and there's this
old guy who you know has conversations
with God and all this kind of stuff that
would have been very difficult to do
living in Arizona it was easy to do it
in Lahore
you